[Music]
I think the number one question that I
get asked is about motivation right and
they're constantly seeking motivation
outside of themselves so first we have
to appreciate that there's a very big
difference between inspiration and
motivation and inspiration is great
inspiration is a source of a catalyst if
you will of change that comes from
outside of you so it could be an episode
of big think that you watched it could
be a song you heard a book you read a
memoir that you saw on who knows some
episode of television and you said you
know what I'm inspired if they can do it
I can do it and it gives you the little
jumpstart on the engine right and the
car gets going and then the month maybe
two all of a sudden you kind of peter
out and the battery dies again and
that's because you need motivation to
stay in motion and motivation is that
why that comes from inside of you and so
you get in these situations where
somebody might be inspired and then find
their motivation and then they get all
the way down the road and they come
right up against that goal and this is
when they get confronted with losing the
very thing that that defense mechanism
and destructive behavior was providing
them and this is where you may find that
you sabotage yourself right at the
one-yard line right before you're about
to leap into that endzone and I would
say at that point get into some
counseling and do some deeper work find
out what it is that is holding you back
that you're engaging in these behaviors
for and then be loving be nurturing be
understanding find ways that are
life-affirming to comfort yourself and
to provide a sense of control that are
not self destructive and on top of that
there should always be a look towards
the future we are always growing and
evolving and progressing
there is no finish line in life
ultimately and I think that's tough for
some to accept because we think okay you
know I cross the finish line now what
you're not dead there's more work to do
look at that take a hard honest look at
yourself and why you've engaged in these
behaviors get rid of some of those
destructive incentives whether it's
dysfunctional relationships in your
friendships set boundaries with people
if it's in your family and you can't
control it remove negative impacts in
your environment and that's one of the
things that's so good about actual
things is that if you change them they
stay changed there's no fighting back
but do some deep self-reflection and
consider getting into some counseling to
look at those things and get the tools
to turn them around
[Music]